[Music]
the white house scrambles to avoid a
crisis amid pelosi visit to taiwan oh
yeah this is [ __ ] wild i thought
china was supposed to blow her out of
there
they didn't keep to their words
they talk and talk and all yeah cause
they said if you visit right they're
like we're gonna blow your ass out of
the air and then everyone was so scared
for her but she was brave in her little
business suit and she's like i'm going
anyways in her in her pink business suit
yeah by the way according to right wing
comedy channels they're saying you know
the way that they got back at us is by
giving us uh pelosi back safely
solid
solid the house speaker stop in taiwan
makes her the highest ranking u.s
visitor there in recent years prompting
threats anger and military maneuvers
from beijing wow you know as soon as she
left though you know what they started
doing is firing off [ __ ] rockets and
they're saying we're just doing some
military exercises
but to me that's kind of like he's like
i ain't [ __ ] you up
yeah
i'm just touching you
you know like setting up [ __ ] tanks
pointed at you yeah they're like [ __ ]
pulling out all they're cleaning all
their guns and loading them i'm just
[ __ ] doing nothing
beat it guys
we're not fighting we're not fighting
that's why world diplomacy is a [ __ ]
joke like the fact that we're all it's
it's just it's just kindergarten [ __ ]
like the way that we have a un too it's
like hey dude it's like
oh man [ __ ] lithuania's getting drunk
oh my god if he starts swinging on
people we all gotta [ __ ] bail his ass
out of this [ __ ] i can't believe this is
pelosi's actual reason to visit because
i heard she went against what biden
wanted right
damn well the biden state department
definitely says we don't recognize
taiwan
but they're not saying like yo [ __ ] you
pelosi don't go but they're tacitly
saying that and then pelosi goes we have
to protect taiwan as a country or
something oh [ __ ] and that's what pissed
china off because they're like they're
not a country she's not supposed to
recognize them i thought pelosi was like
i gotta go check up on my stocks and
investments over there i mean there's
there's
that's well that's part of what their
people are saying too is like like you
know she is invested in semiconductors
and [ __ ] yeah i gotta protect my insider
that's heavily over there yeah so the
white house worked urgently to
de-escalate tensions with china as house
speaker nancy pelosi met wednesday with
taiwanese president tsai
and when other officials during a
high-profile visit to the self-governing
island against the administration's
wishes hoping to head off a geopolitical
crisis amid threats and military
maneuvers right so it was against the
administration why have you a good play
where it's like we told her not to go
just [ __ ] go we told her not to go
but what exactly did they say not like
not to go because bain and hunter are
[ __ ] sucking china's dick so i think
they don't want [ __ ]
pelosi to go over there [ __ ] hunter
has a lot of business in china
white house officials warned that china
is preparing itself for possible
aggressive actions in response to
pelosi's visit beyond this week and they
reiterated forcefully that the chinese
communist party should not use the visit
as a pretext to increase military
activity in and around taiwan straight
we've seen a number of announcements
from the people's republic of china in
just the last several hours that are
unfortunately right in line with what we
had anticipated white house spokesman
john kirby said on tuesday china has
positioned itself to take further steps
and we expect that they will continue to
react over a longer term horizon
now straight up we already know there's
a [ __ ] ton of tension between china and
taiwan
and a lot of people like even in china
i've heard some little some little you
know birdies whispering stuff like that
too that a very very similar russia
ukraine type of situation is going to
happen and it's not going to happen this
year is going to happen within the next
couple years that's exactly how russia
did it we're like it's a military
exercise what are you guys talking about
nah we're just [ __ ] chilling dude and
then last moment they're like we're
inside
yeah and anthony let me tell you
something right now
oh [ __ ] the glasses are coming on okay
that's not gonna happen
the same way that i told you that russia
will not go into ukraine
there's no [ __ ] way that that will
happen thank you
you did it again i actually think you
were one of the first reason people to
tell me that russia was going into you
oh no no no oh i get
i mean uh let's see pelosi's visit has
deeply angered china which for years has
sought to diplomatically isolate the
island and considers any visit by a
high-level foreign dignitary as an
expression of support for taiwanese
independence i wanted to [ __ ] go to
the night market at taiwan now i can't
go what kind of food you get there dude
they have this corner where they got a
lady that boils [ __ ] a lady that steams
[ __ ] a lady that fries [ __ ] a lady that
like there's like
any type of grill stuff so like it's
like you could get like hey you want
some grilled octopus or you want it
boiled or you want it [ __ ] smothered
in like stinky tofu sauce what do you
want and it's like different cooking
techniques it's so [ __ ] good night
market out there is bomb as [ __ ] yeah
yeah and then and then you could get
like some fake ass [ __ ] louis vuitton
and [ __ ] that they don't even make but
it looks real and they could get some
like t-shirts five or two cents or
something yeah
i went i went to the airport i went to
their airport and i was like they can
keep it
virtually all the senior members of
president biden's national security team
have privately expressed deep
reservations about the trip and its
timing said a white house official who
spoke on the condition of anonymity to
discuss internal deliberation but why is
[ __ ] pelosi going rogue and [ __ ] like
she could have done
that [ __ ] could have done a [ __ ]
face time
but she had to make a spectacle out of
it creating tensions like why [ __ ]
google hangouts
everybody's been doing that like she
couldn't just she didn't have to go
there dude like what was she missing
like she's like you know what but
there's this in tao shunga foreign
there's like [ __ ] there's this stinky
tofu that i love
i got this onion pancake man like and on
top of that like i really got it to feng
shui and [ __ ] i want my [ __ ]
reading by this magic like chinese
warlock over there and then like she's
like i gotta go dude so there's really
no public known reason why she went at
all my problem with it is that
my problem with it is that the left and
the right seem to be okay with it so i'm
just like suss all over it i'm just like
yeah i don't trust this [ __ ] at all
actually something going on with it that
i don't know what it is but there's
something going on yeah when they both
don't really criticize it that's when
you're getting maximum [ __ ] yeah like
george collins said anytime there's
bipartisanship exactly that's when
you're getting all the way nobody's
raising a fuss but then china itself is
[ __ ] over it exactly how the [ __ ] i
don't know how they're [ __ ] me but
they're [ __ ] me yeah pelosi
specifically said our uh well
she said
uh the speaker who was accompanied by
several other members of congress
dismissed the notion that her trip was
unduly uh provocative she stressed that
it did not alter america's approach of
strategic ambiguity which neither
supports taiwan's independence nor
opposes it and she cited a variety of
long-standing american policy positions
on china and taiwan
our visit is one of several
congressional delegations to taiwan and
in no way contradicts long-standing
united states policy guided by the
taiwan relations act of 1979. u.s china
joint community communicates and the six
assurances she said in america statement
the united states continues to pose
unilateral efforts to change the status
quo
so basically i hate to break it to her
but uh
ambiguity is opposing it
that is opposition totally yeah
it's it's exactly the same way that
people say that ambiguity about trans
rights opposes trans rights it's like
the same [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and i had you
know my my taiwanese homies are like
why the [ __ ] she had to go visit the
country like you know the second a bunch
of chinese [ __ ] military ships and
planes and stuff go go into six maritime
areas around taiwan just post up getting
ready for [ __ ] it's like because
our house speaker went to go visit
taiwan for
what she's stirring some [ __ ] up and she
doesn't even have to stay there that's
like me coming over to your house and
then you're like neighbors kind of mean
so i start [ __ ] fighting with your
neighbor and i go peace and i go home
and now you gotta [ __ ] live with this
neighbor that you guys might fist fight
how long was she there for
do you know
and talks to the leader and goes
hey you guys should just rejoin china
yeah what was the talks about like what
if that's what i didn't wanted me to
tell you guys
oh that's what you went there to say
they feel all guilty they're like i know
damn all the tanks do u-turns now yeah
they overreacted the tank girl goes
they say sorry for overreacting yeah
they're like god dude you know like with
history and all that with between us
like i had noises damn dude that'd be
[ __ ] funny
not funny but
pelosi would be leading the
congressional visit in taiwan through
wednesday focusing on u.s taiwan
relations security trade the covet 19
pandemic the climate crisis human rights
and other issues of quote mutual
interest
should meet with a bunch of startups out
there for more insider trading
she is really [ __ ] up that veneer of
like u.s submitting to china though you
know what i don't get though it's like
by the time you're like
70 80 pushing on well your face is
melting off right
worth 80 million yeah why the [ __ ] do
you care more about making more like are
you trying to create like legacy at this
point where you just want so much for
your future generations like at that
point
what why you keep hustling maybe you're
not in the clear yet
maybe you owe something because of the
wealth that you committed you you have
to do something or or several so it's
not about the money anymore maybe it's
like you're just you're just observing
it or you're a pawn yeah like she just
has to do it who knows i'm sure by the
scale you know how things scale we're
like so she has 80 mil but i'm sure
she's not the richest person she knows
and i'm sure the 80 million is nothing
to elon yeah and i'm sure whoever person
she respects probably dwarfs her [ __ ]
net worth all i know is you do the right
thing and you get voted out a house or
senate you get shuffled into the defense
industry or you get to go work at any of
these places where they set you up with
a cushy job you don't have to [ __ ]
sweat things and you just get to collect
and collect they don't even make as much
as the silicon valley people they chose
the wrong jobs it's the favorite debt i
believe
at that point you probably owe a lot of
people a lot of actions because the kind
of favor that i like is like hey dude
you've been bringing a lot of [ __ ]
donuts here
now i feel like here's a donut for you
so like i gotta i gotta give you a
cupcake or something
yeah you know like damn
[Music]
that's the kind of favorite you need to
show my i get you a build-a-bear gift
card
and then we're square and then we're
even now no more donuts dude yeah stop
stop bringing it up at night dude with
these donuts i don't like this unfair
thing where you just keep giving and
giving without anything you know in
return
i feel like that gets so tricky though
because then like you just antsy up
every single time and then you just have
to outshine each other about dad yeah
asian dads like asian dad gift giving
you know they're all competing through
like i'll get you yeah
each fruit basket gets bigger and bigger
as you go [ __ ] back and forth but
before you know it they're [ __ ]
giving you a farm and [ __ ] julia do you
recognize taiwan
uh
yeah why not
why not i mean
i don't i don't have any ties to taiwan
per se but
i think i think i do see them as like
they've created themselves like their
own name and they have their own system
but they're not their own country or are
they i mean i see it as their own
country oh shh
you heard it here on jk news and a few
official media sources recognizing julia
is so controversial
i know a country when i see one
you